Hey there, everybody. Ira here. So if you heard our show last week, you know that I had just learned hours before we broadcast that episode that I needed to go into quarantine because a guy who I had shaken hands with five days before that developed symptoms and then tested positive for coronavirus. It is now 12 days since I shook hands with that guy, and I've not developed symptoms. CDC guidelines say that it can happen for up to 14 days, so I am nearly in the clear. A reminder to everybody that people who don't have symptoms can still be carrying the virus and give it to others. Anyway, the world has changed so much, right?
大家好，我是艾拉。如果你们听了我们上周的节目，就知道我在那期节目播出前几个小时才刚得知，我需要进行隔离，因为我在五天前曾与一个人握手，那个人随后出现了症状，新冠病毒检测结果呈阳性。从我与那个人握手到现在已经过去了12天，我还没有出现症状。美国疾控中心（CDC）的指导方针称症状可能会在14天内出现，所以我差不多算脱离危险了。提醒大家，没有症状的人仍可能携带病毒并传染给他人。总之，世界已经发生了巨大的变化，对吧？
One of the striking things about this coronavirus is how differently it affects different people. So some people who get it have no symptoms, or they get mild symptoms, or they experience something like a bad flu. That's particularly young and healthy people, though young, healthy adults are not immune. The CDC put out a report this week-- maybe you saw this-- saying 20% of hospitalized COVID-19 patients are between 20 and 44 years old.
这种冠状病毒最引人注目的一点是它对不同人的影响差异很大。有些人感染后完全没有症状，或者症状轻微，亦或是经历了像重感冒一样的过程。对于年轻人和健康人尤其如此，尽管年轻、健康的成年人也并非免疫。美国疾控中心本周发布了一份报告——或许你们看到了——称在住院的新冠肺炎患者中，20%的人年龄在20岁到44岁之间。
But it's older people, as we all know, who are living in a completely different world these days. If they leave their homes, they're walking around in a world that's suddenly filled with this invisible thing that can kill them with no idea of who around them might have it or what doorknob it might be on. One of our producers, David Kestenbaum, talked to this woman, Tova Rothman, who's 71. Her husband's 74 and has a compromised immune system, so he is in special danger if he comes into contact with the virus. Here's David.
但我们都知道，对于老年人来说，他们如今生活在一个完全不同的世界里。如果他们走出家门，他们就是在这样一个世界里走动：这个世界突然充斥着这种肉眼看不见、却能夺走他们生命的东西，他们根本不知道身边的人谁可能携带病毒，也不知道病毒可能附着在哪个门把手上。我们的一位制片人戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆采访了71岁的托娃·罗斯曼。她丈夫今年74岁，免疫系统受损，因此如果接触到病毒，他将面临特殊的危险。下面请听戴维的报道。
I talked to Tova last weekend, which feels like so long ago. I don't think I would do this now, but we met in person to talk. She lives in my town, in this apartment across from the pizza place, the little movie theater, the Kings supermarket. Her daughter told me she was eager to talk to someone.
上周末我和托娃通了话，那感觉像是很久以前的事了。我想现在我不会再这么做了，但当时我们面对面进行了交谈。她住在我所在的城镇，公寓就在披萨店、小电影院和金斯超市对面。她女儿告诉我，她很渴望和人说话。
For her safety, I checked my temperature before I left the house, washed my hands twice, and wiped down my microphone, though even that is no guarantee. Again, I wouldn't do this now. She came down from her apartment carrying her cell phone and a canister of Clorox wipes.
为了她的安全，我离家前量了体温，洗了两次手，并擦拭了我的麦克风，尽管即便如此也无法保证绝对安全。再说一次，换做现在我不会这么做了。她带着手机和一罐高乐氏消毒湿巾从公寓走下来。
Oh, you brought your own wipes too.
哦，你也自带了湿巾。
Yeah.
是的。
We did the interview on a park bench. If she's a little off-mic sometimes, it's because I'm sitting as far away from her as possible, holding my arms straight out with the microphone. Every move she makes right now requires some impossible calculation. She has to avoid anything that might get her or her husband sick.
我们在公园长椅上进行了采访。如果她有时声音听着不太清楚，那是因为我尽量坐得离她远远的，手臂伸得笔直拿着麦克风。她现在做的每一个动作都需要经过近乎不可能的精确计算。她必须避开任何可能让她或她丈夫生病的东西。
How are you feeling in general?
你总体感觉怎么样？
Overwhelmed, but I feel like that I can master this. I went to Kings across the street. I just try to stay away from people. They have them restocking and restocking. And they actually have better fruit and fresher fruit now. [LAUGHS]
不知所措，但我感觉自己能够掌控这一切。我去过街对面的金斯超市。我只是尽量远离人群。他们一直在补货。而且他们现在的水果品质更好，也更新鲜了。[笑声]
But you're not supposed to get between six feet of people. And millennials are all marching around buying things, and you're, whoa, don't come near me. I must look like I'm crazy, but that's the way it goes.
但是你不应该在距离他人六英尺（约1.8米）以内的范围内。那些千禧一代到处走动买东西，而你心里想的是，哇，别靠近我。我看起来一定像个疯子，但情况就是这样。
This town is a very young town, and so there's a lot of young people and a lot of kids skateboarding. And they're in your face. And you're like, stay away. But they don't understand that.
这个镇是个非常年轻的镇，有很多年轻人和玩滑板的孩子。他们就在你眼前晃悠。而你的反应是，离远点。但他们不理解。
Have you said anything to anybody?
你有没有跟谁说过什么？
No. Wearing my plastic gloves and carrying my canister of Clorox, I think they understand where I'm coming from. [LAUGHS] It sounds so funny.
没有。戴着橡胶手套，拎着我的高乐氏消毒湿巾，我想他们明白我的立场。[笑声] 这听起来太滑稽了。
Her husband, because of his immune system, is stuck in the apartment.
她的丈夫因为免疫系统的问题，被困在公寓里。
My husband is not well. He can't go out, and he's not happy about it.
我丈夫身体不好。他不能出去，他对此很不高兴。
There's TV, of course, but annoyingly, no sports to watch because everything's been canceled. The other night, he had Gunsmoke on, which is really not Tova's thing.
当然有电视看，但烦人的是，因为一切都取消了，没有体育节目可看。前几天晚上，他在看《荒野大镖客》，那可不是托娃喜欢的节目。
So we're not having a great relationship with this. I told him that I was checking on him, and he shouldn't get out of his chair. And he very nastily said, OK, I won't get out.
所以我们在这方面的关系不太好。我告诉他我要去看看他，他不应该从椅子上站起来。他非常刻薄地说，好吧，我不站起来。
Does he say, I want to go outside, and you say, we can't?
他会说“我想出去”，而你说“我们不能出去”吗？
Yeah. He'll say, I want to do something. And I say, you can't. I would take him downstairs, and he could go out and get air in his face. But there's so many surfaces between our apartment and the lobby, and it's only one floor. But there's so much you have to worry about.
是的。他会说，我想做点什么。我说，你不能做。我本想带他下楼，让他出去吹吹风。但我们的公寓到大厅之间有太多表面要接触，虽然只有一层楼。但有太多东西需要担心了。
It is a surreal thing. You just-- you think, what? Every morning, you wake up and think, I can't believe this. Is it real? So, it's real.
这真是件超现实的事情。你只是——你会想，什么？每天早上醒来，你都会想，我真不敢相信。这是真的吗？所以，这是真的。
Tova says her grandfather died from the Spanish flu in 1918.
托娃说她的祖父在1918年的西班牙流感中去世了。
He went to the opera. They used to get tickets where they could stand and pay a lot less. And so he went to the opera, and he was in a crowd. And he got-- he was sick one day and died the next.
他去看了歌剧。他们过去常买那种可以站着观看、票价便宜得多的票。所以他去了歌剧院，身处人群之中。他——他有一天病了，第二天就去世了。
He was 26. I keep thinking about how differently everyone might view this thing, how different our country's response might have been if the virus were as dangerous for younger people.
他才26岁。我一直在想，如果病毒对年轻人同样危险，大家对这件事的看法会有多大不同，我们国家的应对措施又会如何不同。
Maybe we would have reacted faster because, oh, it's only the old people. [LAUGHS] That's how I feel. It wasn't quite as tragic if it's the old people. My friends keep calling and saying, who knew we were the old people, which is true.
也许我们会反应得更快，因为，哦，那只是老年人。[笑声] 我就是这么觉得的。如果是老年人，似乎就不那么悲剧了。我的朋友们一直在打电话说，谁知道我们竟然就是那个“老年人”群体，这确实是真的。
Tova stood up to go back to her husband. And as she did, this guy walked really close to her to throw a tissue in the trash can, as if it was two weeks ago or something. Tova was not happy.
托娃站起身准备回去找她丈夫。就在这时，一个男人从她身边走得非常近，去往垃圾桶里扔纸巾，就好像现在还是两周前或者什么类似的时候。托娃很不高兴。
I was almost ready to throw my canister of wipes at him. He should stay away. Maybe I don't look 71. [LAUGHS]
我当时差点想把我的消毒湿巾罐扔向他。他应该保持距离。也许我看起来不像71岁。[笑声]
I'm sure that's it.
我肯定是因为这个。
Ah, yeah. [LAUGHS]
啊，是啊。[笑声]
OK.
好的。
Oh, very nice meeting you too.
哦，见到你也很高兴。
OK.
好的。
And thank you.
谢谢你。
I called Tova four days later to see how she was doing. She's still going out for walks-- no supermarkets anymore.
四天后我打电话给托娃，看看她过得怎么样。她仍然会出去散步——只是不再去超市了。
That was actually the very last interview that anybody on our staff did with somebody in person, David Kestenbaum's story. We have all been holed up in our own homes, everybody on the staff. We are one of the many businesses that have decided that it's safer for everybody if we're working from home. So everybody's doing interviews over the phone. We're all preparing stories for next week's show about what's happening in the country and in the world.
那实际上是我们的员工采访的最后一个人，也就是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆的那个故事。我们所有人都窝在自己的家里，员工中的每一个人。我们是许多决定居家办公对大家更安全的企业之一。所以每个人都在通过电话进行采访。我们都在为下周的节目准备关于国家和世界正在发生什么的故事。
But in the meantime, until then, thinking about what might be nice to hear on the radio in a moment like this one. I think so much of what is happening now, as we're being told to stay home, and so many of us are either cooped up with our families or reaching out to family members more than usual, and reaching out to the other people we love to see how they're doing, and to worry together about what's going to happen next, we thought, with that in mind, today we would prepare a show of stories that we've made over the years about families and about people trying to find comfort or find answers by turning to their families, including-- we have this one story from 25 years ago of me and my mom back when she was still alive. And I saw her quoted in a national magazine as a sexpert. I had some questions for her, and I called her. We get to that in Act Three.
但在那之前，考虑到在这样一个时刻，收音机里播放什么内容会比较好。我想，现在所发生的事情中，很大一部分是当大家被告知待在家里时，我们很多人要么是被关在家里和家人在一起，要么比平时更多地联系家人，联系我们所爱的人，看看他们过得怎么样，并一起担忧接下来会发生什么。考虑到这一点，我们认为今天应该准备一期节目，分享我们多年来制作的关于家庭的故事，以及人们试图通过转向家人来寻找安慰或答案的故事，包括——我们有这个25年前的故事，关于我和我妈妈，那时候她还活着。我看到她在一本全国性的杂志上被引用为“性专家”。我有一些问题想问她，于是我打了电话给她。我们将在第三幕中探讨。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Hey, Dad. Dad!" So school was cut off in so many places, and kids are home. And we have this story of a parent trying to go about his day and his daughter coming to him over and over with some things on her mind. Stephanie Foo tells what happened.
第一幕，“嘿，爸爸。爸爸！”因为在许多地方学校停课了，孩子们都待在家里。我们有一个故事，讲的是一位父亲试图继续他的一天，而他的女儿一次又一次地带着心中的疑问来找他。斯蒂芬妮·傅讲述了发生的事情。
My friend Matt's older daughter went through one of those hardcore phases, where she got really into asking her dad a lot of questions. She was nine.
我朋友马特的大女儿经历了一个“硬核”阶段，那时她非常喜欢问爸爸很多问题。她当时九岁。
There's the why phase, and then the why phase can turn into the why not and explain, and that endless string of questions, like, why can't I have my own room? How do I get to school? Why can't we have a yard? Can I have a cookie? They're unrelenting.
有“为什么”阶段，然后“为什么”阶段可能会变成“为什么不”以及“解释一下”，还有没完没了的问题串，比如，为什么我不能有自己的房间？我怎么去学校？为什么我们没有院子？我可以吃块饼干吗？这些问题接连不断。
So one night, Matt was working from home, and Rosie was bugging him with her questions.
所以有一天晚上，马特在家里工作，罗茜一直在用她的问题打扰他。
And it was just sort of one after the other after the other. And I was like, all right, look, you got to just give me a minute. I'm working right now. Just go off and write them all down. Make me a list of the questions that you want me to answer, and I'll answer them for you.
就是一个接一个。我就说，好吧，听着，你得给我一点时间。我正在工作。你去把它们都写下来。列一张你想让我回答的问题清单，我会为你回答的。
I thought it was going to be like three or four questions and then a picture of a rabbit or something. And I get this list, and I look at it. And these are the essential, unanswerable questions of life.
我以为那会是三四个问题，然后画个兔子什么的。结果我拿到了这张清单，看了一眼。这些都是关于生命的基本的、无法回答的问题。
Read a few of these questions for me. Start at the very top.
帮我读几个问题。从最上面开始。
OK. So, what is life? Why?
好的。那么，生命是什么？为什么？
That's the first question?
那是第一个问题？
That's the first question. It's the first thing she wants to know.
那是第一个问题。这是她想知道的第一件事。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Where do we go when we die-- heaven? Explain. Another planet? Is heaven another planet? Why is there heaven or hell? Time-- why? Explain.
我们死后去哪里——天堂吗？解释一下。另一个星球？天堂是另一个星球吗？为什么会有天堂或地狱？时间——为什么？解释一下。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Do we make worlds? Do we become like God-- why? Why do you do what you do? How do you know what's true? Who do you miss-- why? Explain.
我们创造世界吗？我们变得像上帝一样吗——为什么？你为什么做你现在所做的事？你怎么知道什么是真的？你思念谁——为什么？解释一下。
Do you miss anyone more than them? And does that change, and how? And if that changes, was it worth missing them in the first place? And my favorite is-- pretty much just my jaw dropped-- why any of this? I mean, my first reaction to them is-- I mean, I'm proud of her. And then I realize I actually have to answer these questions.
你是否比他们更想念任何人？这种情况会改变吗，如何改变？如果改变了，最初思念他们值得吗？我最喜欢的是——我简直惊掉了下巴——为什么会有这一切？我的第一反应是——我是说，我为她感到骄傲。然后我意识到我真的必须回答这些问题。
There are about three pages, single-spaced, of handwritten questions, about 50 questions total. But a promise was a promise, so Matt got to work. He's a professor at West Point, teaches writing. And so he took a professorial approach to it and started researching answers for her, looking up quotes on each topic, spending weeks, sometimes months, writing each answer.
总共有大约三页单倍行距的手写问题，总共大约50个问题。但承诺就是承诺，所以马特开始工作了。他在西点军校当教授，教写作。于是他采取了教授式的方法，开始为她研究答案，查找每个主题的引语，花了数周，有时甚至是数月，来写每一个答案。
What's the shortest and what's the longest you've ever spent, and what's the hardest one?
你花过最短和最长的时间分别是什么，最难的问题是哪一个？
So I think the longest one is one that I haven't finished answering for her yet, which is, what is love?
我想最长的一个是我还没有完成回答的，那就是，什么是爱？
What's been the easiest one to answer so far?
到目前为止最好回答的是哪一个？
Is heaven another planet? No.
天堂是另一个星球吗？不是。
I got him to read me one of the answers he worked hardest on. The answer to time-- why? Explain.
我让他读给我听其中一个他花了最大心血准备的答案。关于“时间——为什么？解释一下”的答案。
Could you read it for me?
你能读给我听吗？
Sure. So tell me what and tell me why, and the burden is on me to justify this to you. Perhaps that's what time means in the end, is justification or a lack of being justified. And I don't really know what justification means. There was an old movie I saw when I was a kid in your grandmother's house--
当然。所以告诉我“什么”和“为什么”，这重担就落在我的肩上，要向你证明这一点。也许这就是时间最终的含义，是证明或者缺乏被证明。我并不真正知道“证明”意味着什么。我小时候在你祖母家看过一部老电影——
He quotes Camus, then brings in the Millennium Falcon, then St. Augustine, then Kierkegaard. Rosie was nine. All his answers are like this.
他引用了加缪的话，然后引入了千年隼号，接着是圣奥古斯丁，然后是基尔克果。罗茜当时九岁。他所有的回答都像这样。
Kierkegaard gets to this point after either/or'ing everything. He says, why did I not die as a baby?
基尔克果在把一切“非此即彼”之后得出了这个结论。他说，我为什么没有作为一个婴儿死去？
I'm a grown-up, and I find it impossible to follow your answers. Honestly, I have not any idea what you're saying.
我是个成年人，我觉得你的回答完全无法理解。老实说，我根本不知道你在说什么。
OK. [LAUGHS] Yeah. I mean, I really don't understand half of what I just said either, to be honest.
好吧。[笑声] 是的。说实话，我真的连自己刚才说的一半内容都不明白。
What his answers do have going for them is sincerity. The time one ends like this.
他的答案确实有真诚的地方。关于时间的那个答案是这样结尾的。
In one of my favorite stories by a guy named William Faulkner, there's a daddy who gives his kid a watch and says, I give you this watch, not that you might remember time, but so that you might forget it for a little while. I can only tell you that time is me turning and turning while the world is turning around a star that turns around a center that turns around the whole time. Among all the other things, the little turning animals on all the little turning worlds, there is me, trying to turn to you.
在威廉·福克纳写的一个我最喜欢的故事里，有一位父亲给孩子一块手表，说，我给你这块手表，不是为了让你记住时间，而是为了让你在短时间内忘记它。我只能告诉你，时间是我在旋转，同时世界围绕着一颗恒星旋转，那颗恒星围绕着一个中心旋转，整个时间都在旋转。在所有事物中，在所有转动的小世界上的转动小动物中，有我，试图转动向你。
OK. And you just told her this answer like this?
好吧。你就这样把这个答案告诉她了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And she--
然后她——
I mean, she would kind of pass in and out of being interested in it. And at the end of it she's just kind of like, oh, yeah, OK. And I'm like, all right, well.
我是说，她有时会对它感兴趣，有时又不感兴趣。最后她只是那种，哦，是的，好的。我就说，好吧，好吧。
I mean, do you see what I'm saying about time? It's a measurement of change. It's an arbitrary human construct, but not, but it feels different, so it's phenomena. She's like, yeah, yeah, OK.
我是说，你明白我关于时间的说法吗？它是一种对变化的衡量。它是一个任意的人类建构，但又不完全是，因为它感觉不同，所以它是一种现象。她就说，是的，是的，好的。
I was like, oh, well, this isn't really exactly what I wanted.
我就觉得，哦，好吧，这并不完全是我想要的。
That's not what you wanted because you were like, oh, this is kind of boring?
这不是你想要的，因为你当时想的是，哦，这有点无聊？
Yeah.
是的。
Rosie has a pixie cut and a cheeky grin. She gave her dad the 50 questions three years ago. She's 12 now. He's been working on getting her answers, but he's only gone through 2/3 of them because it takes him so long to cobble together a response. What I found out talking to Rosie is she didn't even really care about the answers to these questions.
罗茜剪着精灵短发，带着淘气的笑容。她三年前给了她爸爸这50个问题。她现在12岁了。他一直在努力回答她，但他只完成了三分之二，因为他花太长时间拼凑出一个回应了。我和罗茜交谈后发现，她甚至并不真正在乎这些问题的答案。
Questions that I thought that would take him a long time to answer, because at the time I really just wanted to talk to him.
我以为他会花很长时间回答的问题，因为当时我真的只是想跟他说话。
It all started when she first moved to New York City. Before then, she'd been living with her mom and grandparents most of the week. But then her grandpa, who she was really close to, died, and she had to move in with her dad during the week instead. At the same time, she started at a new school where the kids either ignored or bullied her, and she felt lost. One day, she came home from school and decided she needed to do something about it.
这一切始于她第一次搬到纽约市时。在此之前，她大部分时间都和妈妈及祖父母住在一起。但后来她非常亲近的祖父去世了，她不得不工作日搬去和爸爸住。与此同时，她进了一所新学校，那里的孩子要么无视她，要么欺负她，她感到很迷茫。有一天，她放学回家，决定做点什么。
I was lonely, and I felt a little sad that nobody had really stepped out to say, oh, hey, it's going to be OK. I'll be your friend. So that's when I really, really needed somebody to talk to.
我很孤独，我感到有点难过，因为没有人真正站出来说，哦，嘿，一切都会好起来的。我会成为你的朋友。所以那时我真的、真的需要有人说话。
So you didn't have anybody to talk to at school?
所以你在学校没有人说话？
No.
没有。
And then at home?
那在家里呢？
No. That's really why I felt like, oh, this is my dad. He's a really important person. I love him very much. I really want to become closer with him. I wish there was something that I could do to make us closer.
没有。这就是为什么我真的觉得，哦，这是我的爸爸。他是一个很重要的人。我非常爱他。我真的想和他变得更亲近。我希望有什么事情能让我们变得更亲近。
Did you feel like your dad wasn't paying enough attention to you?
你觉得你爸爸没怎么注意你吗？
Yeah, a little bit. Or not a little bit, yeah.
是的，有一点。或者说不只是有一点，是的。
What was he doing instead?
他当时在做什么？
He was writing papers on his computer. And I knew, at the time, how important it was, but part of me still wished that, like, put down all the screens, put down everything else, and just talk. So I wrote all the questions down, and they were big questions because I know my dad. And if it's a little question, he'll elaborate on it, and he'll make it a big deal. So if you times that by a big complex question, that would be a huge talk.
他在电脑上写论文。我当时知道那有多重要，但我心里还是希望，放下所有的屏幕，放下其他一切，只是聊聊天。所以我把所有问题都写了下来，而且它们都是大问题，因为我了解我爸爸。如果是一个小问题，他会详细阐述，把它当成一件大事。所以如果你把它乘以一个复杂的大问题，那会是一次巨大的谈话。
Is it true that you weren't talking to her much at the time?
当时你是不是没怎么跟她说话？
No, I think I was talking to her all the time. I would tell her it's time to get up and go to school. I would tell her that it was time to do her homework. I would tell her that she needed a new jacket. Yeah, I mean, I talked to you all the time.
没有，我觉得我一直在跟她说话。我会告诉她该起床去上学了。我会告诉她该做作业了。我会告诉她需要一件新外套。是的，我是说，我一直都在跟你说话。
Maybe you're noticing the purely logistical nature of everything he mentioned. It certainly didn't get past Rosie.
也许你注意到了他提到的所有事情纯粹是后勤性的。罗茜肯定没漏掉这一点。
I talked to you all the time.
我一直在跟你说话。
Yeah, but to me, it's not really the same thing. So conversation and talking are completely different things. Talking could be a range from, oh, hey, what's up? And conversation is you're deep in thought, and you're looking, and you're making eye contact, and you're really enjoying the presence of somebody else.
是的，但对我来说，那并不完全是一回事。谈话和说话是完全不同的事情。说话的范围可以是，哦，嘿，怎么了？而谈话是你沉思其中，你在观察，你在进行眼神交流，你真的在享受另一个人的存在。
Rosie's a smart kid, yeah, but this is the thing I really admire about her. Matt was a single dad with two kids, going to school and trying to make the rent at the same time. Telling him to pay attention to her didn't cut it, so she figured out something else. I read this short story recently about a successful con man whose motto was, make them want to give you the thing you want to take. Rosie made her dad want to give her attention by making an opportunity to do what he loved, ponder over life's big questions.
罗茜是个聪明的孩子，是的，但这是我真正钦佩她的地方。马特是一个单身爸爸，带着两个孩子，又要上学又要付房租。告诉他多关注她并没有起到作用，所以她想出了别的办法。我最近读过一个短篇小说，讲的是一个成功的骗子，他的座右铭是：让他们想要给你你想拿的东西。罗茜通过创造机会让他做他热爱的事情——思考人生的大问题，从而让爸爸想要给她关注。
My dad was kind of hard-shelled, I guess. And so it took a lot. I had to keep asking these questions and keep wondering. For me, it was just-- I had to keep going, and keep trying, and keep being this little bird that goes on your shoulders, like, I'm now your friend.
我爸爸有点外冷内热。所以这花了很多功夫。我不得不一直问这些问题，一直好奇。对我来说，这只是——我必须坚持下去，一直尝试，一直像这只落在你肩膀上的小鸟一样，比如，我现在是你的朋友了。
Do you feel like it sort of taught him how to talk to you better?
你觉得这是否教了他如何更好地跟你说话？
Yeah, definitely. Over the past three years, we've really worked on having actual conversations than him just answering questions for me because we practice it.
是的，绝对是。在过去三年里，我们真正致力于进行实际的对话，而不是他只是回答我的问题，因为我们练习过了。
Rosie never knew that her dad spent months and months writing down each answer. Matt only told her when I started working on this story. And she said she felt like, what? Are you kidding me?
罗茜从来不知道她爸爸花了几个月又几个月的时间写下每个答案。马特只有在我开始制作这个故事时才告诉她。她说她觉得，什么？你在开玩笑吗？
I had no idea that he was doing all these things, and it was just a big surprise for me. If I could, I would definitely just say forget the questions. I just want to talk.
我根本不知道他在做所有这些事情，这对我来说只是一个巨大的惊喜。如果可以，我绝对会说忘了那些问题吧。我只是想聊聊天。
So you're like, well, you don't even have to go through all that trouble.
所以你就说，好吧，你甚至不用费那么大劲。
Yeah.
是的。
Just hang out.
只是待在一起。
Yeah.
是的。
Rosie said this to her dad when she found out, and it really threw him for a loop.
罗茜发现后对她爸爸说了这些，这真的让他不知所措。
Yeah, it was a complete waste of time. [LAUGHS]
是的，这完全是浪费时间。[笑声]
I mean, what a complete waste of time to come up with these big, extensive projects that-- they were definitely less important to them than just listening to them.
我是说，想出这些大型的、广泛的项目来，这真是完全浪费时间——相比于倾听他们，这些对他们来说肯定不那么重要。
Hm.
嗯。
What is time-- why? Explain. Well, I can tell you what I don't want time to be. I don't want time to be something where I am just figuring out that I need to shut up and make some time to listen to this little kid before it's too late.
时间是什么——为什么？解释一下。嗯，我可以告诉你我不想要时间成为什么。我不想要时间成为那种我只是在发现我需要闭嘴并抽出一些时间来倾听这个小孩的地方，在一切为时已晚之前。
Rosie really started asking the questions because she wanted to know that she wasn't alone and that everything was going to be OK. Now she enjoys hearing the answers because they remind her that that's true. That's why one of her favorite answers is the ending of time-- why? Explain-- the part about all of the planets turning around themselves and in the middle of it Matt turning towards Rosie.
罗茜问这些问题真的是因为她想知道她并不孤单，一切都会好起来。现在她很喜欢听这些答案，因为它们提醒她这是真的。这就是为什么她最喜欢的答案之一是关于“时间——为什么？解释一下”的结尾——关于所有行星围绕自身转动，而在这一切中间马特转向罗茜的部分。
One of the meanings of that is even though everything is happening around you, he just wants to know about me a little more, I guess. And a thing that I really like about that is because he just uses these sentences that make me happy when I read them.
其中的一个意思是，即使周围发生的一切都在发生，他只是想多了解我一点，我想。我真正喜欢它的一点是因为他只是使用了这些我在读的时候让我感到快乐的句子。
It's kind of funny. When he read this to me, he sort of choked up a little bit.
挺有趣的。当他读这些给我听的时候，他有点哽咽。
Yeah. He likes to be kind of a one-expression person, but when he reads stuff like this he gets all emotional. In the car ride here, he was like, oh, I love you so much. And he was tearing up and looking out the window, so.
是的。他喜欢表现得像是一个只有一种表情的人，但当他读这样的东西时，他会变得很感性。在开车的路上，他会说，哦，我太爱你了。他会泪流满面，看向窗外，所以。
[LAUGHS] You look so happy about that.
[笑声] 你看起来为此感到很高兴。
Yeah, it's pretty great.
是的，这很棒。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So people have been asking these big, important questions like, why are we here? What is life-- forever? And do you think that the real big reason why we ask it is to have a reason to talk to each other?
所以人们一直在问这些重大的、重要的问题，比如，我们为什么在这里？生命是什么——永远吗？你认为我们问这些问题的真正重大原因是有一个理由互相交谈吗？
No. I think that philosophers actually really do wonder about these things, and they don't use it so that they can talk to their dads more. They use it because they really wonder about these things, and they want to know everything about it. But for my personal use, yes. That's exactly it.
不。我认为哲学家们确实真的很想知道这些事情，他们使用它不是为了让他们能更多地跟爸爸说话。他们使用它是因为他们真的想知道这些事情，他们想了解关于它的一切。但就我个人而言，是的。完全是这样。
Matt does still want to keep answering Rosie's questions for her, but as for the hardest question, what is love, I don't think Rosie needs her dad to explain that to her anymore. She gets it.
马特确实仍然想继续回答罗茜的问题，但至于那个最难的问题，“什么是爱”，我想罗茜不需要她爸爸再向她解释了。她懂了。
Stephanie Foo. She's currently writing a book about complex PTSD. These days, Rosie is a freshman in high school, and she goes by Rory now. We checked in with her. She says she's using her time cooped up at home with her family right now to draw and listen to music. She says everybody is getting along.
斯蒂芬妮·傅。她目前正在写一本关于复杂创伤后应激障碍（CPTSD）的书。如今，罗茜是一名高中新生，她现在叫罗里。我们跟她确认过。她说她现在正在利用被关在家里与家人在一起的时间来画画和听音乐。她说大家相处得很好。
Act Two, "Call Me Maybe." So many of us are concerned right now about our older relatives, especially our parents and grandparents. And this story, in the most literal way, is about reaching out over the phone. Sean Cole put it together.
第二幕，“也许给我打个电话”。我们很多人现在都在关心我们的年长亲属，特别是我们的父母和祖父母。而这个故事，以最字面的方式，讲述了通过电话联系。肖恩·科尔整理了这个故事。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Yo, Sean. This is your mom. I wasn't home.
喂，肖恩。我是你妈。我刚才不在家。
About four or five years ago, I started saving all my mom's voicemails, thinking, she's not going to be around forever. I'm going to want to hear her voice when she's gone, though somehow I didn't extend that thought to I could hear her voice right now if I picked up the phone. She had a talent for the form. With some of them, it almost feels like I'm talking to her, except she's playing both parts.
大约四五年前，我开始保存我妈妈所有的语音留言，我想，她不会永远都在。等她走了，我会想听听她的声音，虽然我不知何故没有想到，如果我拿起电话，我现在就能听到她的声音。她在这一方面很有天赋。听着其中的一些，感觉几乎就像我在跟她对话，只不过她分饰了两角。
What time is it? Oh, it's 6:52, huh? Yeah, it's later than I thought. I can't believe it's still light out.
几点了？哦，6点52分，是吗？是的，比我想象的要晚。真不敢相信天还亮着。
Decided to go to the Royal for supper tonight, so that's what we did. We went early, and we are back early. So I don't know what you're doing. So this is me. C'est moi. I'm here. Right. Yo aqui.
决定今晚去皇家餐厅吃晚饭，所以我们就去了。我们去得早，也回来得早。所以我不知道你在做什么。所以这是我。就是我。我在这里。没错。在这儿。
C'est moi. That's "it's me" in French. Sometimes there's not much more than that.
“C'est moi”（这是我）。那是法语里的“就是我”。有时除了这个没有更多的了。
C'est moi. Love you lots. Talk to you soon. Bye.
就是我。非常爱你。很快再跟你聊。再见。
This one's even shorter.
这个更短。
C'est moi. Bye.
就是我。再见。
But of course, all the messages boil down to her saying, in one creative way or another, please call me back. Sometimes she was a lot more direct about it.
但当然，所有的信息归根结底都是她在以某种创造性的方式说，请回电话给我。有时她要直接得多。
(SLOWLY) Don't forget to call your mother. Goodbye.
（缓慢地）别忘了给你妈妈打电话。再见。
Actually, here's the one that I always tell people about when I'm talking about her messages. It's like she sort of circles and then goes in for the kill.
事实上，这是我每次谈论她的留言时都会告诉人们的那一条。就像她先绕个圈子，然后直接切入正题。
I heard you on the radio on Sunday, and I knew it was you because I can recognize your voice, even though it's been a long time since I've heard it on the phone. So anyway, I love you lots and lots. Call me when you think of it, if you ever do. Love you. Bye.
我在周日的广播里听到了你的声音，我知道是你，因为我能认出你的声音，尽管我已经很久没有在电话里听过它了。所以，总之，我非常爱你。当你想到的时候给我打个电话，如果你真的会想的话。爱你。再见。
My mom-- her name was Pat-- she died on September 28, 2015 at 4:22 in the morning. It was relatively sudden and totally unexpected. And as much as I thought I was preparing myself for that moment, I wasn't prepared. It's true I didn't call enough, but she was still the first person I thought to call when something huge happened, good or bad.
我妈妈——她叫帕特——她在2015年9月28日凌晨4点22分去世了。这相对突然且完全出乎意料。尽管我以为我在为那一刻做准备，但我并没有准备好。确实我打的电话不够多，但当发生什么大事时，好或坏，她仍然是我第一个想到要打电话的人。
I loved talking to her. She was funny, as you can tell, and smart. She wrote technical manuals in the early days of personal computing. Later in life, she lugged a lot of pro-grade camera equipment around the world, taking pictures. And yet, she had a hard time figuring out her smartphone. The last recording I have from her saved on my phone was a pocket dial.
我喜欢跟她说话。正如你所看到的，她很幽默，也很聪明。她在个人计算的早期编写技术手册。后来在生活中，她背着很多专业级的摄影器材满世界拍照。然而，她却很难弄明白她的智能手机。我手机里保存的她最后一段录音是一个误触的口袋电话。
[SCUFFLING]
[摩擦声]
This goes on for three minutes.
这持续了三分钟。
[SCUFFLING CONTINUES]
[摩擦声继续]
Did you go for your walk this morning?
你今天早上去散步了吗？
No, I didn't make it this morning. I figured that I was pretty busy.
没有，我今天早上没去。我觉得我挺忙的。
After Mom died, I started calling home a lot more to talk to my stepdad, Ed Hacker. He and I never really had a phone relationship when my mother was alive. It was more the classic thing of, you want to say hi to Ed? And then we'd verbally clap each other on the back and then back to Mom. These days, it's not weird for us to spend almost two hours on the phone together.
妈妈去世后，我开始更频繁地打电话回家，跟我的继父埃德·哈克聊天。我妈妈在世时，我和他并没有真正的电话关系。更多是那种经典的，“你想跟埃德打个招呼吗？”然后我们口头上互相拍拍后背，然后又转回妈妈那。如今，我们进行两个小时的电话交谈已经不再奇怪了。
Then I had to give tweets out, so--
然后我不得不发推文，所以——
You are the most active octogenarian on Twitter that I know about.
你是我认识的最活跃的八旬Twitter用户。
Well, I try to send out about six or seven tweets.
嗯，我尽量发六七条推文。
What did you send this morning?
你今天早上发了什么？
Oh, I sent about three or four from--
哦，我发了三四条关于——
I think of how annoyed my mom would be if she knew this, but I'm now performing the exact telephone behavior she wanted from me when she was around, except now with Ed. I call about once a week on average, and it's always me initiating the calls now. At first, of course, it was mainly to make sure he was holding up OK and to make sure I was holding up OK.
我想如果我妈妈知道这件事会多厌烦，但我现在正在做她还在世时希望我做的完全相同的电话行为，只不过现在对象换成了埃德。平均每周我打一次电话，现在都是我主动发起的。起初，当然，主要是为了确保他一切都好，也确保我自己一切都好。
But even now, when I miss a week, it eats at me. I'm thinking, got to call Ed, got to call Ed. It's like an injustice that he's getting this treatment and not her, and I keep trying to square it somehow. But when I put this to Ed, he basically said it's really not that big a mystery.
但即使是现在，当我错过了一周时，这也会困扰我。我想，得给埃德打电话，得给埃德打电话。他受到这种待遇而不是她，这感觉像是不公正，我一直试图以某种方式平复它。但当我把这一点告诉埃德时，他基本上说这真的不是什么大谜团。
Kind of obvious that if one parent dies, you realize that the other one may not be that far off, that he will go too, or she. So the scarcity, just like in economics, makes the value go up.
有点显而易见，如果一位父母去世了，你会意识到另一位可能离那也不远了，他也将离开，或者是她。所以稀缺性，就像在经济学中一样，使价值上升。
I never thought of this in economic terms before.
我以前从来没从经济学的角度考虑过这一点。
Well, it's true of many things. If the population is very low--
嗯，许多事情都是这样。如果人口非常少——
Ed's 87. He taught philosophy and logic at a university in Boston for a lot of years, which is fitting because Ed is very logical and philosophical. He's always quoting one or another great thinker. For fun, he does math. He and my mom got together when I was six. He moved in when I was 11.
埃德87岁了。他在波士顿的一所大学教了很多年的哲学和逻辑，这很合适，因为埃德非常有逻辑且有哲学头脑。他总是引用某位伟大的思想家的话。为了消遣，他做数学题。我和妈妈在我六岁时在一起。他在我11岁时搬进来。
And I think he's right that I call because I'm more aware than ever that one day he won't be on the other end of the phone, but it's more than that too. Even though we have all of these other people in our family whom we love, it got to feeling like Ed's the other one Mom's death happened to, like he and I were the ones who mutually needed to talk about Mom and to hear about her.
而且我认为他是对的，我打电话是因为我比以往任何时候都更清楚，有一天他不会在电话的另一端，但也不仅限于此。即使我们在我们的家庭中还有所有其他我们爱的人，这开始让人觉得埃德是妈妈去世后的那个“幸存者”，就像他和我是那些必须互相交流关于妈妈的事情，并听到关于她的一些事情的人。
I feel that, yes, I can talk to you about Pat because you're willing to talk to her about it.
我感觉到了，是的，我可以跟你谈论帕特，因为你愿意谈论她。
To you about it, yeah.
跟你谈论这件事，是的。
And it makes a big difference to me.
这对我有很大影响。
It does?
真的吗？
Of course.
当然。
I'm so glad to hear that.
我很高兴听到这个。
Because you lost the same person, even if it's somewhat similar if somebody else has lost someone else, like these groups in which everyone has lost a spouse. And their memories are different. You never met that other person that died, and you really don't care. I mean--
因为你失去了同一个人，即使如果其他人失去了别人，类似于这些每个人都失去了配偶的团体，情况有点相似。他们的记忆是不同的。你从来没见过那个死去的其他人，而且你真的不在乎。我是说——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You care about your loss. I mean, you know.
你在乎的是你的损失。我是说，你知道的。
Yeah.
是的。
Let's be honest.
说实话。
Are you on the deck now?
你现在在露台上吗？
I am.
是的。
Having a smoke?
在抽烟？
I am.
是的。
For a long time, my mom was a third invisible person in all of these conversations, but we've both noticed we're talking about mom less and less. People told me this would happen, but I didn't really believe them, or I didn't want to. Time slouches on. You wake up to different thoughts in the morning. And when you call home, the first thing you say isn't, how are you holding up?
很长一段时间里，我妈妈在所有这些对话中都是第三个隐形人，但我们俩都注意到我们谈论妈妈越来越少了。人们告诉我这会发生，但我并不真正相信，或者我不愿意相信。时间缓缓流逝。你早上带着不同的思绪醒来。当你打电话回家时，你说的第一句话不再是，“你还好吗？”
It used to be that you would kind of mark how long it had been. You'd say, I can't believe it's been three-- it'll be three months on Monday, or I can't believe it'll be nine months on Thursday or whatever.
过去通常你会标记已经过了多久。你会说，我真不敢相信已经三个月了——周一就满三个月了，或者我真不敢相信周四就九个月了，诸如此类的。
Well, I still keep track of the time.
嗯，我还在记录时间。
You do?
你还在记录吗？
Yeah. And I also have an app on my computer, all three of them, which is set to tell me how many days since Pat died.
是的。我电脑上还有一个应用程序，三个都在上面，它们被设置为告诉我帕特去世多少天了。
You do?
真的吗？
I do.
是的。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
So this way-- I'm going there right now to see what my apps are. Well, it's been 22 months and three days since she's died. Or if you want, one year, 10 months, and three days. Or if you want, 96 weeks.
所以这样——我现在就要去看看我的应用程序。嗯，帕特去世已经22个月零3天了。或者如果你想要的话，一年零10个月零3天。或者如果你想要的话，96周。
And what do you feel like, looking at that?
看着那个，你有什么感觉？
Don't have any particular feeling. It's just that it's amazing that it's almost two years.
没有什么特别的感觉。只是令人惊讶的是快两年了。
Hm.
嗯。
It's like saying, I remember.
就像在说，我记得。
Yeah, I feel like I need something like that, some sort of-- I just feel like I don't think about her enough.
是的，我觉得我需要像那样的东西，某种——我只是觉得我想她的时间不够多。
Well, that you'll have to explain. Why should you think more?
嗯，那得由你来解释了。为什么你应该想得更多？
I don't-- it's just like--
我不——这就像——
Is it guilt or something?
是因为内疚或者什么吗？
It's not guilt, no. It's--
不是内疚，不是。这是——
You feel like you'll honor her more by thinking about her?
你觉得通过想她，你会更尊重她吗？
It's like, yeah, I want to honor her more by thinking about her, and it also feels like there's something going on in me all the time that I'm not acknowledging that leaks out in these other ways. And I just miss her, and so it's like I need to put that missing somewhere.
这就像是，是的，我想通过想她来更尊重她，而且也觉得我身体里一直有些东西在发生，我没有意识到，以其他方式泄露出来。我只是想念她，所以感觉我需要把这种想念放在什么地方。
Well, you have a photograph of Pat?
嗯，你有帕特的照片吗？
Yeah. I have one up on the wall in my office.
有的。我办公室墙上有一张。
OK. Take another one. And every day, move it from one spot to another in your apartment.
好的。再拿一张。每天，在你的公寓里把它从一个地方移到另一个地方。
That's a really good idea. Did you just think of that?
那是个非常好的主意。你刚才想到的吗？
Yes. That makes it sort of a ritual.
是的。这让它成为一种仪式。
But the truth is I already have the ritual I need. I don't do it every day, but I do it just about every week. I call Ed. We talk. For this specific need I have, it turns out he's the perfect person to call. Maybe you've got somebody like that, a personal Ghostbuster when there's something strange in the neighborhood, when things are looking their worst, that person who will know what you're talking about, even if they can't understand what you're saying. And all you got to do is call.
但事实是我已经有了我需要的仪式。我不是每天都做，但我几乎每周都做。我给埃德打电话。我们交谈。对于我有的这个具体需要，事实证明他是最完美的人选。也许你也有这样的人，一个在你身边发生奇怪的事情、情况最糟糕的时候的个人“捉鬼敢死队”，那个会知道你在说什么的人，即使他们无法理解你在说什么。你所要做的就是打电话。
Sean Cole. When he checked in with Ed this week, Ed was the same as always and doing well. He turns 90 in April.
肖恩·科尔。他本周与埃德通了电话，埃德一如既往，过得很好。他四月就90岁了。
Act Three, "Mom." OK, so this is a story we first put on the air in 1996. And yes, our program has been on the air for a long time.
第三幕，“妈妈”。好吧，这是一个我们在1996年首次播出的故事。是的，我们的节目已经播出了很长时间。
Diane, who's putting together this part of the show with me, producer Diane Wu, she listened to this recording, and she told me that I sound exactly the same in it as I sound today, which-- I don't know. Is that a good thing? Is that not a good thing? Shouldn't a person grow? I think I should sound at least a little different.
黛安，正在和我一起整理节目这一部分的制片人黛安·吴，她听了这段录音，告诉我我在里面听起来和今天一模一样，这——我不知道。这是好事吗？这是坏事吗？一个人不应该成长吗？我想我听起来至少应该有点不同。
Anyway, here is how I introduced this story back then in 1996. Quick warning, before the story starts, that this story acknowledges the existence of sex. OK, here we go.
总之，这就是我在1996年介绍这个故事的方式。快速警告，在故事开始之前，这个故事承认性的存在。好吧，我们要开始了。
Our parents can surprise us with what they don't tell us, with what they don't talk about, especially when it comes to sex. Recently I had this experience. An ex-girlfriend was in the gym, looking through a copy of Marie Claire magazine, women's magazine. And there was an article in it on women's fantasies, their sexual fantasies-- what do your man's dirty daydreams reveal about what he wants from you?
我们的父母在他们不告诉我们的事情、他们不谈论的事情方面会让我们惊讶，尤其是在性方面。最近我有过这种经历。一个前女友在健身房里，正在看一本《嘉人》（Marie Claire）杂志，女性杂志。里面有一篇文章是关于女性幻想的，她们的性幻想——你男人的肮脏白日梦揭示了他想要从你那里得到什么？
In the article, six sexperts-- that was the word they used, "sexperts"-- reveal the six most common male sex fantasy scenarios. So my ex-girlfriend is reading. And there, in the third paragraph, one of the sexperts turns out to be my mother.
在那篇文章中，六位性专家——这是他们用的词，“性专家”（sexperts）——揭示了六种最常见的男性性幻想场景。所以我的前女友正在读。在那里，在第三段，其中一位性专家竟然是我妈妈。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Mom?
嘿，妈妈？
Yeah.
是的。
It's Ira.
我是艾拉。
Yeah?
嗯？
So I'd like to do a little interview.
我想做一个小采访。
OK.
好的。
OK. So Mom, can I read to you a quote from an article?
好吧，妈妈，我可以给你读一段文章里的引用吗？
Of course.
当然。
OK. Here it is. "Your man wants a woman who excites him through her own excitement. You could stimulate yourself while he watches or let him participate by moving his hand to where you want it."
好的。在这里。“你的男人想要一个通过她自己的兴奋而让他兴奋的女人。你可以在他观看时刺激自己，或者通过把他的手移动到你想要的地方让他参与进来。”
Yeah?
嗯？
That's you being quoted in Marie Claire.
这是你在《嘉人》里被引用的内容。
[LAUGHS] You're kidding. What is [INAUDIBLE]?
[笑声] 你在开玩笑吧。什么是[听不清]？
All I know is that Anaheed was at the gym, and she opens up Marie Claire to an article called "Men's Sexual Fantasies." And it says at the top, "Here, sexperts reveal the six most common scenarios, unlock the secret longings and psyches of the modern men who fantasize." And you basically are one of the sexperts.
我只知道阿纳希德当时在健身房，她翻开《嘉人》看到了一篇题为“男人的性幻想”的文章。顶部写着，“在这里，性专家揭示了六种最常见的场景，解锁那些有幻想的现代男人内心深处的秘密渴望和心理。”而你基本上是性专家之一。
Yeah. Yeah, I am.
是的。是的，我是。
I didn't really know you were a sexpert.
我真的不知道你是性专家。
What did you think I was?
你以为我是什么？
[LAUGHS] Just another Jewish mom and psychologist.
[笑声] 只是另一个犹太妈妈和心理学家。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
So it wasn't like you were a sexpert and you were keeping it from your family?
所以并不是你作为一个性专家在向你的家人隐瞒什么？
You're talking about my family meaning my children, not my husband?
你是在说我的家人是指我的孩子，而不是我的丈夫？
Yeah.
是的。
Because he knows that I'm a sexpert.
因为他知道我是性专家。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And you can call him to verify that.
你可以打电话给他确认这一点。
I think I'm just going to let that go.
我想我还是算了吧。
[LAUGHS] But my children always seem embarrassed if I discuss anything sexual. So therefore, I tend not to around them.
[笑声] 但我的孩子们似乎总是因为我讨论任何性方面的事情感到尴尬。因此，我在他们身边倾向于不讨论。
When would you try to discuss something sexual with us?
你什么时候会试图和我们讨论性方面的事情？
I might make a joke or say something that had a sexual connotation, and I'd get this disapproval.
我可能会开个玩笑或说一些有性暗示的话，然后我会得到这种不赞同的反应。
I don't think that that's true.
我不认为那是真的。
No?
不吗？
Yeah. Actually, I mean, it doesn't affect me in any way to think that you and Dad would be sexual with each other. In fact, I even remember, as a teenager, understanding that and being kind of reassured by it.
是的。其实，我是说，认为你和爸爸在彼此之间有性生活并不会在任何方面影响我。事实上，我甚至记得，作为一个青少年，理解这一点并因此感到某种程度的放心。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
Does that make any sense?
这有道理吗？
It makes a little bit of sense, but it really doesn't cover all the situations, if I'm just telling a joke or talking about somebody else. And I think it has to do with boundaries. And I think it has to do with that children, even adult children, do not like to regard their parents' sexuality.
有一点道理，但它确实不能涵盖所有情况，如果我只是开个玩笑或谈论别人。我认为这与界限有关。我认为这与孩子，甚至成年子女，不喜欢关注父母的性生活有关。
Hm. You know something? You're actually convincing me.
嗯。你知道吗？你真的在说服我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, let's do a little scientific test. Can you think of a sexual joke? You just tell one right now, and I'll tell you my reaction.
好吧，让我们做一个小小的科学测试。你能想到一个性笑话吗？你现在就讲一个，我会告诉你我的反应。
I can't think of one.
我想不到一个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You know what I'm feeling right now? I'm feeling a profound--
你知道我现在感觉如何吗？我感到一种深沉的——
Oh, actually, I heard a wonderful--
哦，其实，我听过一个很棒的——
Wait, wait, no.
等等，等等，不。
I heard a wonderful joke, but I don't even know if it's a joke or a story. This is something that might be true, that when Neil Armstrong walked on the moon and he said, one giant step for man and one-- what is it-- one giant step for mankind or whatever--
我听过一个很棒的笑话，但我甚至不知道它是笑话还是故事。这是件可能真实的事情，当尼尔·阿姆斯特朗走上月球时，他说，这是个人的一小步，人类的一大步——那个是什么——个人的一小步，人类的一大步。
One small step for man, one giant step for mankind.
个人的一小步，人类的一大步。
Right, right. That's it, one small step for man, one giant step for mankind. And then he also said, good luck, Mr. Gorsky. And for years, people have been asking him what that meant. And he would never tell them.
对，对。就是那个，个人的一小步，人类的一大步。然后他还说，祝你好运，戈尔斯基先生。多年来，人们一直问他那意味着什么。但他从来不告诉他们。
And then this year, someone brought it up again. What did you mean when you said, good luck, Mr. Gorsky? And he said, well, I can tell now because Mr. Gorsky died this year.
然后今年，有人又提起了它。当你说明“祝你好运，戈尔斯基先生”时是什么意思？他说，嗯，我现在可以说了，因为戈尔斯基先生今年去世了。
When I was a little boy, Mr. Gorsky was our next door neighbor. And I was playing outside one day, and their bedroom window was open. And I heard Mrs. Gorsky say, oral sex? You want me to give you oral sex? You'll get oral sex from me the day that boy next door walks on the moon.
我小时候，戈尔斯基先生是我们隔壁邻居。有一天我在外面玩，他们的卧室窗户开着。我听到戈尔斯基太太说，口交？你想让我给你口交？你得等那个隔壁小孩走上月球那天才会从我这里得到口交。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Well, now I'm examining my own feelings. And I have to say, I did get very nervous there in a way that does not correspond, perhaps, with shrugging my shoulders at the notion of you having some sexual life and sexual thoughts.
好吧，现在我正在审视我自己的感受。我不得不说，我当时确实变得非常紧张，这也许与我对你有性生活和性想法这一观念耸耸肩的反应并不相符。
Yeah.
是的。
So let me read you some of your other quotes here.
那么让我读一下你的一些其他引用。
All right.
好的。
In the fantasy of man dominates woman, you're quoted as saying-- says Dr. Glass, quote, "In a caring relationship, it's certainly not abusive or unhealthy if the fantasy is played out in a light, teasing way." You're also quoted extensively in fantasy number five, spontaneous encounter with a beautiful stranger. The key quote is this one, as far as I'm concerned-- "Go to a restaurant, and, at first, pretend you don't know each other," suggests Dr. Glass-- which, when I read that, it actually explained some dinners I've had with you and Dad.
在“男人支配女人”的幻想中，你被引用为说——格拉斯医生说，引用，“在一段充满关怀的关系中，如果这个幻想是以一种轻松、戏谑的方式演绎出来的，那肯定不是虐待或不健康的。”你在幻想五“与美丽的陌生人进行自发邂逅”中也被广泛引用。关键引用是这个，就我而言——“去一家餐馆，起初，假装你们彼此不认识，”格拉斯医生建议——当我读到这个时，它实际上解释了我跟你和爸爸一起吃过的一些晚餐。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I thought. Well, you didn't talk very much between the two of you.
我想。嗯，你们俩之间话不多。
No, no. That was just the opposite.
不，不。那正好相反。
So have you actually-- have you-- have you done this? Have you gone to a restaurant with Dad and pretended that you didn't know each other?
那么你真的——你——你做过这个吗？你和爸爸去过餐馆并假装你们彼此不认识吗？
No.
没有。
No. But if you did, you're saying that--
没有。但如果你这样做，你是说——
We've gone to restaurants with you and pretended we didn't know you.
我们和你去过餐馆，并假装我们不认识你。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What do you mean by that?
你是什么意思？
Well, when you were younger, and--
嗯，当你年轻的时候，而且——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
--and let's say that your manner of dressing didn't exactly conform to the style--
——比如说你的着装风格并不完全符合风格——
All right, all right. I think everybody-- yeah.
好了，好了。我想大家都——是的。
--of the other people in the restaurant.
——餐馆里其他人的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Back when Daddy-- Daddy would look at you, and he would start popping Gelusil when we'd go out to eat. And I'd say, now Barry, people are going to look at him, they're going to look at us, and they're going to know that we did not pick out his clothes.
回到爸爸——爸爸看着你，他就会开始嚼胃药，当我们出去吃饭时。我会说，现在巴里，人们会看他，他们会看着我们，他们会知道我们没有挑选他的衣服。
So now that I know that you're this big sexpert, do you have any sex advice for me?
所以现在我知道你是这个伟大的性专家了，你有什么性建议给我吗？
Find a nice girl, and get married. [LAUGHS]
找个好女孩，结婚。[笑声]
That's not sex advice.
那不是性建议。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We always end up this way, don't we?
我们总是这样收场，不是吗？
With that particular advice. Yeah, that's-- I know. [LAUGHS] I know. I could ask you any question, and that would be the advice.
伴随着那个特别的建议。是的，那——我知道。[笑声] 我知道。我可以问你任何问题，那都会是建议。
That's right.
没错。
My mom, Dr. Shirley Glass, back in 1996. In that recording, she is a year younger than I am today. Coming up, when a dad you know so well does something very, very uncharacteristic, what does it mean? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我妈妈，雪莉·格拉斯医生，回到1996年。在那段录音中，她比我今天年轻一岁。接下来，当你非常了解的爸爸做出非常、非常不寻常的事情时，这意味着什么？那在一分钟后从芝加哥公共电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass, speaking to you today not from a studio, but from home because our staff is working from home. And also, I am on quarantine. I'm actually talking to you from inside a closet. It's an old recording trick, with the idea that the clothes absorb sound. I will just say, it's very cramped.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯，今天不是从录音棚，而是从家里和你交谈，因为我们的员工正在居家办公。而且，我正在隔离中。我其实是从壁橱里跟你交谈。这是一种旧的录音技巧，想法是衣服可以吸收声音。我只能说，这里非常狭窄。
Today on our program, with kids out of school all over the country and businesses closed, and people hunkered down at home with family, and also lots of people far from family and the ones they love, reaching out and worried for them, we have put together a show of family stories that we've made over the years. Both the stories in this next part of our show are people turning to their dads over the telephone with a question. This first one, Act Four, "It Takes a Villa," comes from Neil Drumming.
今天在我们的节目中，全国各地的孩子都放假了，企业关闭了，人们缩在家里与家人在一起，而且有很多人远离家人和他们所爱的人，联系他们并为他们担心，我们整合了一期关于家庭故事的节目，这些故事是我们多年来制作的。在我们节目接下来的这一部分中，两个故事都是关于人们通过电话向他们的父亲询问问题。第一个，第四幕，“租个别墅”，来自尼尔·德拉明。
In the summer of 1982, my dad did something unexpected, something that seemed unbelievably indulgent. He took me, my mom, my brother, and the youngest of my three sisters on the most epic road trip any of us could have possibly imagined at the time. We piled into my dad's Buick Skylark and drove from Queens, New York to the World's Fair in Knoxville, Tennessee, where a robot danced for us, and then down into Orlando, Florida.
1982年的夏天，我爸爸做了一些意想不到的事情，一些看起来令人难以置信地放纵的事情。他带着我、我妈妈、我哥哥以及我三个妹妹中最小的一个，踏上了我们在当时能想象到的最史诗般的公路旅行。我们挤进爸爸的别克Skylark车里，从纽约皇后区开车到田纳西州诺克斯维尔的世界博览会，那里有一个机器人在为我们跳舞，然后一直开到佛罗里达州奥兰多。
This was a big deal. Before this, going away meant visiting relatives in South Carolina and sitting uncomfortably among aunts and second cousins whose names I would forget before we'd even pulled out of their dusty driveways. This trip was not country heat and sipping sugar water on some rickety porch while listening to the inscrutable conversation of grown folk. It was what going 1,000 miles from home should feel like.
这是一件大事。在此之前，出门意味着去南卡罗来纳州看亲戚，坐在阿姨和二表亲中间感到不自在，而我在离开他们尘土飞扬的私道前就会忘记他们的名字。这次旅行不是乡村热，不是在破旧的门廊上喝糖水，同时听着大人们不可理解的谈话。这就是离家1000英里应该有的感觉。
We cruised down a brightly-lit street called International Drive. We stayed at a Holiday Inn taller and more grand than any I'd ever seen. Sunlight streamed in through a hole in the ceiling, a hole that was supposed to be there.
我们沿着一条灯火通明的街道叫国际大道行驶。我们住进了一家比我见过的任何一家都更高大、更宏伟的假日酒店。阳光从天花板的一个洞里流进来，一个应该就在那里的洞。
Our parents took us to a building that looked like a pile of poached eggs, but was actually Xanadu, House of the Future. And everywhere, along every roadside, billboards promised that the most magical scene still awaited us, this place, Disney World. By all accounts, it was paradise for kids. But between the gas, and the hotels, and the eating out, my dad quickly discovered how expensive taking even 60% of his brood on a Disney vacation could be. He was resigned to do it, but he wasn't above working the angles.
父母带我们去了一栋看起来像一堆水煮蛋的建筑，但实际上是Xanadu，未来之家。到处，沿着每一条路边，广告牌都承诺最神奇的景象仍然在等着我们，这个地方，迪士尼世界。根据所有的叙述，这对孩子们来说是天堂。但汽油、酒店和在外就餐的费用加起来，爸爸很快发现带着他后代中哪怕60%去迪士尼度假是多么昂贵。他认命去做，但他并不排斥“运作”一下。
He found out that you could get cheap tickets to the Magic Kingdom if you just signed up to sit through an hour or so spiel from someone pitching timeshares. He was in. The hard sell went down at the Disney Village, a branded mini mall near the famous theme park. My mom, dad, and a handful of other determined parents stowed their kids in a room full of toys that had been conveniently provided by the salespeople. The parents set about the business of listening, or not, waiting patiently for the moment when the closers would stop shilling and start handing out the Disney discounts.
他发现如果你只是报名参加一个小时左右推销分时度假房的人的演讲，你就可以以便宜的价格买到魔法王国的门票。他加入了。那场硬推销发生在迪士尼村，一个著名的主题公园附近带品牌的迷你购物中心。我妈妈、爸爸和少数其他意志坚定的家长把他们的孩子关在销售人员方便提供的装满玩具的房间里。家长们开始听，或者不听，耐心地等待推销员停止兜售并开始分发迪士尼折扣的时候。
But while we kids were in another room throwing LEGOs at one another, something surprising happened. My dad bit. He went into a closed room to get three-day passes just so that I could eventually lose my glasses on Space Mountain, and he came out with a deed, the deed to something he and my mom were now calling our villa.
但当我们在另一个房间里用乐高积木互相投掷时，发生了令人惊讶的事情。我爸爸上钩了。他走进一个封闭的房间去买三天通票，只是为了让我最终能在太空山上弄丢我的眼镜，而他出来时拿着一份契约，一份他们现在称之为“我们的别墅”的东西的契约。
My father was a bold man, but in retrospect this is the most impetuous action that I have ever seen him take. It cost him about $5,000, which he paid in installments. In 1982, for a guy with five kids, who never made more than $33,000 a year at his day job, it was a considerable investment.
我父亲是一个勇敢的人，但回想起来，这是我见过的他采取的最冲动的行为。它花了他大约5000美元，他分期付款。在1982年，对于一个有五个孩子、在日常工作中从未赚超过33000美元一年的家伙来说，这是一笔相当大的投资。
For those unfamiliar with timeshares, it may be hard to wrap your head around buying a vacation home that you never really own. You pay upfront for it. There's an annual maintenance fee, but you only get to stay in it once a year or so, usually for a week at a time. It almost sounds like some sort of scam, and sometimes it is. But it didn't turn out that way for us. Instead, it became a fixture in my family.
对于那些不熟悉分时度假房的人来说，可能很难理解购买一个你从未真正拥有的度假屋。你预付钱。有年度维护费，但你每年只去住一次左右，通常是一次一周。它听起来几乎像某种骗局，有时确实如此。但对我们来说并没有那样。相反，它成了我家里的固定节目。
My father had chosen, as our week, the first week in July. And so every year, during one of the hottest months of the year, we would head down I-95 as always. But now when we pulled into South Carolina to see relatives, that was only a pit stop on the way to our true destination. We had transformed from people who went away to a family who went on vacation.
我父亲选择的我们那一周是7月的第一个星期。所以每年，在一年中最热的月份之一，我们就像往常一样沿着95号州际公路南下。但现在当我们开车去南卡罗来纳州看亲戚时，那只是前往我们真正目的地的一站。我们已经从去度假的人转变为一个去度假的家庭。
Our villa was number 317, a two-bedroom apartment with an enclosed back porch that looked out onto a small man-made lake complete with fish, ducks, and another summer word that I learned, "gazebo." My brother chased cicadas and lizards. For my sister, the only swimmer among my siblings, there was a pool. There were tennis courts and bikes to rent. The general store even offered a collection of the latest movies on laser disk.
我们的别墅是317号，一个带封闭后门廊的两居室公寓，俯瞰着一个人工小湖，里面有鱼、鸭子，还有一个我学到的夏天的词，“凉亭”（gazebo）。我哥哥追逐蝉和蜥蜴。对于我姐妹中唯一一个游泳的人来说，有一个游泳池。有网球场和可供租用的自行车。杂货店甚至提供了一系列激光影碟上的最新电影。
That first trip, I was eight. As I got older, I moved from the gazebo to the game room and then the gym, trying to meet other kids my age. My mom busied herself in the kitchen, making lunches, or sat by the lake and watched the ducks. My dad shepherded us through It's a Small World and Epcot Center.
那第一次旅行，我八岁。随着我长大，我从凉亭搬到了游戏室，然后是健身房，试图结识和我同龄的其他孩子。我妈妈忙着在厨房里做午餐，或者坐在湖边看鸭子。爸爸带领我们游览了“世界是个小地方”（It's a Small World）和艾波卡特中心（Epcot Center）。
Our summers went on like this, pretty much exactly like this, probably until I finished high school. I honestly loved it. I looked forward to this trip every year. And even though it was only a week, it was almost always the highlight of my entire summer.
我们的夏天就是这样过的，几乎完全就是这样，可能直到我高中毕业。我真心喜欢它。我每年都盼望着这次旅行。即使它只有一周，也几乎总是整个夏天最精彩的亮点。
But when I think about it now, it occurs to me my dad pretty much orchestrated this thing that became so important to our lives, and I have no idea whether or not he ever enjoyed it himself. In fact, it didn't seem like he did. I can't recall actually seeing him happy.
但现在想起它时，我想到爸爸几乎策划了这个对我们生活变得如此重要的事情，而我根本不知道他自己是否曾享受过它。事实上，看起来他并没有。我不记得曾真正看到他快乐过。
Neither does my brother. He says Dad was pretty much the same at the timeshare as he was at home. Sometimes he'd go for walks alone, but often he just sat on the couch and watched TV. I asked my sister. She said he must have been happy, but she doesn't remember witnessing it either. It seems like such a simple question, but I just wanted to know, did he enjoy himself?
我哥哥也不记得。他说爸爸在分时度假屋时几乎和在家时一样。有时他会独自去散步，但通常他只是坐在沙发上看电视。我问了我的姐妹。她说他一定很快乐，但她也不记得见过他快乐。这看起来是一个如此简单的问题，但我只是想知道，他自己享受了吗？
At the risk of embodying the most tired trope in all of modern masculinity, I will say my father and I never really got along. He was strict, his house had a lot of rules, and he believed in corporal punishment. And the sting of that conflict stayed with me as an adult. But since my mom passed away last year, I've been trying to connect with him more. I gave him a call.
冒着体现现代男性气质中最令人厌倦的陈词滥调的风险，我会说我和父亲从来没有真正相处融洽。他很严厉，他的房子有很多规则，他相信体罚。那种冲突的刺痛感一直伴随着我进入成年。但自从我妈妈去年去世后，我一直试图更多地与他联系。我给他打了个电话。
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
Hello?
喂？
Yes?
是的？
Hey, it's Neil.
嘿，我是尼尔。
Yes.
是的。
Is it a bad time?
现在方便吗？
It's about who?
你是谁？
I said, is it a bad time?
我说，现在方便吗？
No, no. I was just playing solitaire. Yeah. I didn't know whether it was the drugstore or not.
不，不。我刚才在玩纸牌。是的。我不知道这是不是药房打来的。
Are you waiting for a call from the drugstore?
你在等药房的电话吗？
No, they'll call. They'll give me a call no matter when it is.
不，他们会打来的。无论什么时候他们都会给我打电话的。
My dad is 83 years old now and living alone in Florida. Talking to him can be awkward and not just because his hearing is going. I asked him point blank if he liked going to the villa. He told me that when he was growing up, he barely ever left South Carolina.
我爸爸现在83岁了，独自住在佛罗里达州。和他说话可能会很尴尬，不只是因为他的听力下降了。我直截了当地问他是否喜欢去别墅。他告诉我，当他成长时，他几乎从没离开过南卡罗来纳州。
I didn't know nothing about nothing else. You saw things in magazines and stuff.
我对其他任何事情都一无所知。你从杂志上看到各种东西。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
The first time I knew about a dentist, I was in the Army.
我第一次知道牙医是在我参军的时候。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
But I just thought it was a good idea that our kids see something other than their surroundings and where they were born.
但我只是觉得让我们的孩子看到除了他们周围环境和他们出生地之外的东西是个好主意。
Yeah.
是的。
My dad grew up poor on a farm, one of 12 children. He says he only finished high school because by the time he was old enough, he was the one driving the bus. Sometimes when there were athletic events at other schools, he'd get to drive the teams and learn what the nearby towns were like.
我爸爸是在农场里贫穷长大的，是12个孩子之一。他说他只读完了高中，因为当他大到那个年纪时，他就是开校车的人。有时当其他学校有体育赛事时，他会去开校车运送球队，了解附近的城镇是什么样子的。
In 1953, he was drafted into the Army, which had only recently been integrated. They sent him to Colorado and Indiana, and it wasn't great. He says the Army was really not into black people back then. So those were his travel experiences when he was young. I was hearing a lot of this for the first time, and as it turns out, that's at least partially my own fault.
1953年，他被征入伍，军队最近才实现种族融合。他们把他送到科罗拉多州和印第安纳州，情况并不太好。他说军队那时候确实不喜欢黑人。所以那是他年轻时的旅行经历。我第一次听到很多这样的事情，事实证明，那至少部分归咎于我自己。
The reason why we never talk about it, because it just wasn't the kind of thing that you guys seemed to be interested in.
我们从不谈论它的原因，是因为这看起来不是你们感兴趣的那种事情。
Really? So we just didn't seem like we were interested as kids?
真的吗？所以我们小的时候看起来对它不感兴趣？
Yeah, right.
是的，没错。
Yeah, I probably wasn't so interested back then, back when the two of us were constantly challenging each other. I was always either afraid of him or angry at him, hiding from him, or planting my feet to confront him. It never crossed my mind to try to understand him. But nowadays, my dad feels to me like some kind of living cold case, a million-page brief that is no longer redacted. Maybe it's because I'm now at the age he was when I was born, but I retroactively find his every decision fascinating, even the ones that aren't so surprising on the surface.
是的，我那时可能确实没那么感兴趣，当时我们俩不断地互相挑战。我一直要么怕他，要么生他的气，躲着他，或者站稳脚跟去面对他。理解他从来没有跨过我的脑海。但如今，我爸爸给我的感觉就像某种活着的“冷案”，一份不再被删减的百万页简报。也许是因为我现在到了他生我时的年纪，但我回顾性地发现他每一个决定都很迷人，即使是那些表面上看起来并不那么令人惊讶的决定。
Why Florida?
为什么选择佛罗里达？
It was advertising. You get to hear something about Florida and then this thing, Disney World. After we started going, they built Epcot. They built Animal Kingdom.
那是广告。你从佛罗里达听说了一些事情，然后这个东西，迪士尼世界。我们开始去之后，他们建了艾波卡特中心。他们建了动物王国。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
And they advertise them a lot.
而且他们做了很多广告。
Yeah.
是的。
Not many people were going. We were probably the most vacationing people in our area.
没有多少人去。我们可能是我们地区度假次数最多的人。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't know of any other family that went on vacation every year. We did.
我不知道还有哪个家庭每年都去度假。我们去了。
My dad was obviously proud that he'd gotten the timeshare, but pride, strictly speaking, does not constitute joy. It didn't answer the question of whether or not he was actually happy spending those summer weeks with us at the villa. Instead, he kept trying to make me understand why he brought us there in the first place. And his explanation, his reasoning reach back to memories and past experiences that not only had I never heard, but that kind of blew my mind.
我爸爸显然为他买了分时度假房感到自豪，但严格来说，自豪并不构成快乐。这没有回答他是否真的很高兴和我们在别墅度过那些夏天的几周。相反，他一直在试图让我明白他为什么要带我们去那里。而他的解释、他的推理追溯到了一些我不但从没听说过，而且让我大开眼界的记忆和过去的经历。
I tell you, probably where I got the whole idea-- when we were in school, every summer you had to try to think of something that you could write about when you'd go back to school, because you're going to have to write something about what you did this summer. Well, we never had anything to write about when I was going to school. And you didn't think plowing a mule, or picking peaches, or stuff that you had to normally do-- you didn't think that was so exciting to write about.
我告诉你，我整个想法可能来自这里——当我们在学校时，每个夏天你都得尝试想出一些你可以写的东西，当你回到学校时，因为你回到学校必须写写你这个夏天做了什么。嗯，我上学时从来没有什么可写的。而且你不会想到耕驴，或者摘桃子，或者你通常必须做的那些事情——你不觉得那有多令人兴奋可以写下来。
Yeah.
是的。
So we made up lies about what we did. Well, every summer you guys went on vacation, you could write about something that you did, or saw, or someplace you went.
所以我们编造了关于我们做了什么的谎言。嗯，每个夏天你们都去度假，你们可以写关于你们做过、看过或去过的地方的事情。
Yeah. What did you do during the summers?
是的。你夏天做什么？
When, this year?
嗯，今年？
No, no, when you were in school.
不，不，当你上学时。
[LAUGHS] Worked.
[笑声] 工作。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's what I tried to tell you.
这就是我试图告诉你的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
We talked for over an hour. It was one of the longest conversations that I can remember us ever having. Every now and then, I'd try to steer him back to the question I wanted him to answer.
我们聊了一个多小时。这是我记忆中我们进行过最长的谈话之一。偶尔，我会试图引导他回到我想让他回答的问题上。
So I know I asked you this a bunch of times. I keep asking you the same question. You can tell me to stop asking you if you want, but did you have fun yourself?
所以我知道我问过你很多次了。我一直问你同一个问题。如果你想的话，你可以叫我停止问你，但你觉得开心吗？
Yeah. See, I don't regret anything because it looked to me like I was doing what I was supposed to do. And to see you kids happy was to be happy too. And you guys could always come in and do whatever it is, and go back out to the pool or whatever.
是的。你看，我不后悔任何事情，因为它看起来我是在做我应该做的事情。看到你们孩子们快乐就是快乐。而且你们总是可以进来做任何事，然后回到游泳池或什么的。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
I remember you guys playing out there and hanging around the bushes and stuff.
我记得你们在那里玩，在灌木丛周围转悠之类的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I thought it was great.
我觉得这很棒。
That's a kind of enjoyment I hadn't considered. I live more selfishly. Also, his answer was hard to take in, to reconcile with the distance I felt between us at the time, back when he would retire to the couch to watch TV or we went off to play on our own. Maybe he was watching me play in the bushes and getting a kick out of it, but I didn't know that. Still, I was happy at the villa, and my dad says he was too. I'm glad I know that.
那是我没考虑过的一种享受。我活得更自私。而且，他的回答很难接受，很难与我当时感到的我们之间的距离相协调，那时他会退到沙发上看电视，或者我们自己去玩。也许他看着我在灌木丛里玩，并从中得到了乐趣，但我不知道。不过，在别墅我很快乐，我爸爸说他也很快乐。我很高兴知道这一点。
All right. So I have been talking to you for an hour. I should probably let you go. But hey, is it OK if I call back this week and just talk? I want to hear more stuff since I didn't seem interested when I was a kid. I didn't realize that was why you didn't tell us stuff. So now I'll just ask. Is that OK if I could--
好了。我跟你聊了一个小时了。我可能应该让你去休息了。但是嘿，如果我这周再打电话回来只是聊聊天可以吗？我想听听更多的事情，因为当我还是个孩子时我似乎并不感兴趣。我没意识到那就是你没告诉我们事情的原因。所以现在我只是会问。如果我可以——这样可以吗？
The only thing I'd do is get up, and sometimes I'm outside just walking around. Sometimes I sit down. Sometimes I go ride the bike. And I do this just to keep busy.
我唯一会做的是起床，有时我在外面只是到处走走。有时我坐下来。有时我去骑自行车。我这样做只是为了保持忙碌。
Yeah.
是的。
You can call me anytime.
你可以随时给我打电话。
All right. I'm going to go back to work.
好的。我要回去工作了。
OK.
好的。
Bye, Dad.
再见，爸爸。
Bye.
再见。
Neil Drumming. He says his dad, who's 87, is emphatically not freaked out over COVID-19.
尼尔·德拉明。他说他87岁的爸爸，明确地没有被新冠病毒吓坏。
Act Five, "Let's Talk Radio."
第五幕，“谈谈收音机”。
We'd like to ask you this question, my friend. Do personal problems and worries have you down? Are you disturbed by business problems, marriage problems, or emotional problems? See Mrs. K, reader and advisor. Mrs. K, formerly of Europe, gives you a reading and answers all your questions for just $1.00. And you'll feel much better.
我的朋友，我们想问你这个问题。个人问题和烦恼让你消沉了吗？你被商业问题、婚姻问题或情感问题困扰了吗？去看看K太太，读者和顾问。曾经在欧洲的K太太给你进行一次解读，只花1美元就回答你所有的问题。你会感觉好多了。
OK. So this is my father in 1956, three years before I was born. He's 23 years old in this recording. And it's amazing, to me, anyway, hearing him so young, doing something I know so well, trying to sound like you're just talking, totally relaxed, when, in fact, you're reading.
好了。所以这是我爸爸在1956年，在我出生前三年。他在录音中23岁。这很神奇，对我来说，听到他如此年轻，做着我如此熟悉的事情，试图听起来像你只是在说话，完全放松，而事实上，你是在读稿。
And coming up right now, news about a wonderful appliance from Norman R. Mitchell just for the homemakers, as we said before. We're talking about an electric dryer. And, my friend--
现在接下来是，关于来自诺曼·R·米切尔的一款很棒的电器的消息，专门针对家庭主妇，正如我们之前所说。我们谈论的是一台电动干衣机。而且，我的朋友——
My father started in radio when he was 19, the same age I was when I started. He began at the college station at the University of Maryland, then after graduation he got a job spinning records at a commercial station in Baltimore. He loved it. He continued doing this on Sunday mornings while he was in the Army, stationed in Virginia. That's where this recording is from.
我父亲19岁时就开始从事广播，和我刚开始时一样的年龄。他始于马里兰大学的校园电台，毕业后他在巴尔的摩的一家商业电台找到了一份播放唱片的工作。他很喜欢。当他在弗吉尼亚州驻扎服兵役时，他继续在周日早上做这件事。这段录音就是那时制作的。
And at some point my mom got pregnant a second time with me, and he decided to quit radio. It just didn't pay enough. The most he ever made at a radio job was $90 a week, which wasn't much money even then. And at that point he became the person that I knew him as, a certified public accountant. Years ago, I called him for a story for our show to ask about that decision to leave radio, and it was interesting. There was no sentimentality at all, like nothing.
在某个时候，我妈妈第二次怀孕了，有了我，他决定退出广播。它付出的报酬不够。他在广播工作中赚的最多的就是每周90美元，即使在当时那也不是很多钱。从那时起，他成了我所认识的那个人，一名注册会计师。多年前，我为了节目的一个故事打电话给他询问离开广播的那个决定，这很有趣。没有任何多愁善感，就像什么都没有。
By that time, I had realized that radio was not for me. What happened would be a new program director would come in, and if you weren't the apple of that guy's eye then you were out of a job. You got to go start looking for a job again. Even though that never happened to me, I could see it happening to other people. And I wanted to be in control of my own destiny, and I decided that it wasn't going to work out. Radio was not going to work out.
到那时，我已经意识到广播不适合我。发生的情况通常是新节目总监进来了，如果你不是那个家伙的“眼中钉”，那么你就丢掉工作了。你得去重新寻找工作。即使这种情况从来没发生在我身上，我也能看到它发生在别人身上。而且我想掌握自己的命运，我决定它不会成功的。广播不会成功的。
And that was 1959?
那是1959年？
Yeah.
是的。
The year I was born.
我出生的那一年。
Right.
没错。
Are those two things related?
这两件事有关联吗？
Not at all. [LAUGHS]
一点也没有。[笑声]
It sounds like they are.
听起来好像是。
No, they're not. No, they're not.
不，它们没有。不，它们没有。
I don't know if he wants to take me out of the equation, so I don't feel bad for him quitting radio, but I don't believe him. I do believe that, even in his private moments, today he doesn't regret the decision. His hearing is so bad these days, even with hearing aids, I doubt that he'll hear this story on the radio or online.
我不知道他是否想把我从方程中去掉，所以我不会为他退出广播感到难过，但我并不相信他。我相信，即使在他私人的时刻，今天他也不后悔这个决定。他的听力这些天很差，即使有助听器，我怀疑他是否会在广播或网上听到这个故事。
I talked to him a couple times this week. He turns 87 on Monday, so part of the population in greatest danger right now. He said he and my stepmom aren't going out. They just figured out how to get groceries delivered. And I'm worried for them.
本周我跟他谈了几次。他周一就87岁了，所以是现在处在最大危险中的那部分人口。他说他和我的继母不出门。他们刚搞清楚如何把杂货送到家。我为他们担心。
Well, all the stars are on record, and all the records star on the Sunday morning carousel. Coming up for you right now, our featured top tune of the day, number one in the record stores we visited this week in Baltimore.
嗯，所有的明星都在录音上，所有的唱片都在周日上午的旋转木马上。接下来是为您准备的，我们今日精选的顶级曲目，在我们这周在巴尔的摩访问的唱片店中排名第一。
Our program was produced today by Diane Wu. Our staff includes Emanuele Berry, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Tony [? Lynn, ?] John [? Elgin, ?] Danielle Elliott, and Chris Crawford.
我们的节目今天由黛安·吴制作。我们的员工包括埃曼纽尔·贝里、苏珊·伯顿、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、努尔·吉尔、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢托尼·林恩、约翰·埃尔金、丹妮尔·埃利奥特和克里斯·克劳福德。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Trying to be civic-minded and conserve on toilet paper, he tried out a bidet for the first time this week.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。这份《美国生活》由PRX，即公共广播交流中心，传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。为了尽到公民责任并节省卫生纸，他这周第一次尝试了坐浴盆。
I was like, oh, well, this isn't really exactly what I wanted.
我就说，哦，好吧，这并不完全是我想要的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。